it hardly looks like a place at breaking
point with the beaches of Los Angeles
County and now the front line in a war
that's currently being lost every day
brings a record number of cases and
closing the beaches for the 4th of July
weekend
is a test for people here stay away will
see the virus spiral out of control most
it seems want to do the right thing
why not yesterday why not today why
Friday like each day goes by fewer
people are being considered oh they're
not scared anymore are they ought to be
it's a big deal because the numbers are
you know going up I feel that more and
more people are realizing you know what
the numbers aren't dropping we have to
take this more serious so I think by
closing the beach the pier it's another
wake-up call I feel like people don't
get their stuff together we're just
going to be doing this for a very long
time here in Manhattan Beach as across
Los Angeles some of the reopening have
been reversed and it's the mayor who
says closing the beaches now is a
mistake I think everyone agrees on a few
things we agree that the young and the
healthy are least likely to get Kovan we
agree that kovat is least likely to be
transmitted outdoors and we know that
the beach is a wide-open space with lots
of social distancing so to my mind it
does not make sense to close the beaches
where the young and the healthy do
gather but California's governor is
warning of more action to come we'll be
doing more to focus on enforcement in
this state and for businesses like
restaurants that have paid months worth
of parking charges to put seating in the
spaces on the road outside its all new
uncertainty
in 53 years repairing shoes here bill
cotta has never seen such unease you
can't burn down your house because you
got termites that's not the answer there
do you of course I understand we have to
do the the masking the social distancing
the more cleaning the more carefulness
but when you close things down for six
weeks eight weeks people have to have a
way to make a living and they had to
have a purpose in life
public health officials here say it was
big gatherings during America's last
holiday weekend at the end of May that's
driving the big spike in cases now a
repeat on Independence Day they say
could do unthinkable damage
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles